[Music]
the suicide squad ties in with its
predecessor as a reboot and therefore
also plays in the same world as the
blockbuster from 2016.
what's new is on the one hand the
framework plot and on the other hand the
team
the reason for this is among other
things the comic adaption of david ayer
which was a failure for many fans and
critics despite its financial success
the reboot will be directed by james
gunn after mel gibson has dropped out as
potential director
with a new constellation of characters
gun wants to ignore part 1 and lead the
blockbuster in a completely new
direction
among others margot robbie is harley
quinn joel kinnaman as rick flack idris
albus bloodsport john cena as peacemaker
david tesmelschen as polkadot man and
many more are involved recently director
gunn also announced that we shouldn't
get too attached to the presence of
individual characters
a significant number of them will die a
surprising screen death during the
course of the film there will also be no
shortage of elaborate sets and special
effects as james gunn
stated in an interview with empire
magazine a week ago the special effects
supervisor is supposed to even think
that more special effects are used for
this movie than for
all marvel movies together whether the
fans will agree with this
can be found out from august 6 2021
[Music]
you